quebecor lance une plateforme de
diffusion en continu que musique une
sorte de spotify québécois l'entreprise
cherche aussi à acheter le cirque du
soleil avec nous ce soir pierre karl
péladeau président et chef de la
direction de quebecor bonsoir monsieur
péladeau
bonsoir monsieur fignon d'abord des
nouvelles de votre entreprise
quebecor a quand même annoncé près de
1000 mises à pied à la fin du mois de
mars 200 employés mis à pied chez
vidéotron également le 17 avril
comment vos quebecor la première chose
effectivement que nous devons indiquer
les mises
maintenant on appelle ça des mise à
disponibilité faut savoir que toute
l'activité de détail comme vous le savez
été mis sur pause les activités détails
pour vidéotron constitue un volet quand
même assez important il y avait d'autres
activités qui elle était assujetti
pardon excusez moi à la mise en pause
donc les activités devaient arrêter
je pense notamment aux activités
distribution de ligne de musique donc
tout ça constitue et donc les 1000
personnes auxquelles il est fait
référence
par la suite il ya eu donc les mesures
qui ont été annoncées par le
gouvernement est peu à peu nous avons
repris nos activités et donc ce n'est
plus 1000 personnes là qui ont été
appelés à perdre leur emploi et je pense
que c'est important il y aura aussi de
retenir que nous avons procuré à nos
employés le différentiel entre la
prestation qui constitue l assurance
emploi et leur salaire donc pour la
grande majorité d'entre eux donc il y
avait 95 % des salaires qui était
assurée ça vous empêche pas d'investir
en tout cas parce que là il ya le seul
du soleil d'un côté puis à votre que
musique que vous lancez aujourd'hui qui
est une forme de spotify québécois est
ce que ce sera plus facile que sur
spotify par exemple de découvrir des
artistes québécois
écoutez c'était quand même un certain
nombre d'années que quebecor évolue dans
le domaine culturel et dans le domaine
de la musique et il nous apparaissait
donc très important de faire en sorte de
pouvoir procurer une plateforme de
l'édition numérique toutes les activités
ou les initiatives en matière de
numérisation en matière de numérique
elles sont importantes les médias
d'information sont distribués de façon
numérique déjà ou s'il il ya beaucoup de
télévision donc avec l'hélico met illico
sur le sans fil est également distribuée
de façon numérique et il nous manquait
mais ils vont avoir d'autres initiatives
également qui vont suivre
mais ce volet de la musique nous
apparaissait importe
est ce que vous allez me payer mieux les
artistes que spotify peut le faire c'est
une question évidemment qui est à la
réflexion de tous ceux et celles qui à
l'heure actuelle évolue dans le milieu
et de leur réponse oui si pour faire
simple pour une raison assez simple
parce que nous avons l'intention donc de
mettre l'accent sur la musique
québécoise donc ancré à cette notoriété
en faisant les efforts de
commercialisation qui sont requis pour
justement générer davantage des doutes
tout savoir et heures au bénéfice de
l'industrie tout ça va être au bénéfice
de l'écosystème et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons eu le privilège
d'être associé aussi étroitement avec
les organismes de droits que ce soit la
seule qui que ce soit l'adisq qui était
présente avec nous ce matin donc dans la
communication que nous avons faite lors
de la conférence de presse vous voulez
acheter le cirque du soleil également
lettre envoyée au gouvernement fédéral
vendredi puis un communiqué encore cet
après midi pour dire que vous voulez
acheter le cirque du soleil mais on sent
que le cirque du soleil ne veut pas être
acheté par quebecor pourquoi bell offre
alors demandé sais pas si on peut et on
doit conclure de la façon dont vous le
faites vous en voyez quand même une mise
en demeure au journal de montréal
affirmant qu'ils avaient des
informations fausses et trompeuses à
leur sujet dans l'objectif de faire
baisser le prix la valeur en quelque
sorte pour que quebecor puisse acheter
au meilleur prix
mais je pense que non que il nous avons
dû le journal de montréal et la
direction de l'information ont répondu
ce matin aux allégations qui était c'est
lille qui ont été donc faite par mise en
demeure qui d'ailleurs un petit peu
curieusement été reçus ici à 20 que le
journaliste de la presse nous apprend
que nous ayons connaissance même de la
mise en demeure donc on a un peu de
difficulté à comprendre donc les tenants
et aboutissants de cette opération
ceci est un donc il y donne le droit de
l'homme en question si le cirque du
soleil a vraiment un intérêt pourquoi le
cirque du soleil fait ça on a
l'impression que le cirque ne veut pas
été achetée par quebecor c'est quoi le
cirque est ce que c'est la direction est
ce que ce sont les actionnaires est ce
que ce sont les créanciers
ce que nous savons à l'heure actuelle
monsieur fignon et la chose et public
non qu'ils sont en défaut en vertu de
leurs obligations ils ont eux-mêmes donc
la direction mentionné que il pourrait
avoir recours à la loi pour la
protection contre les créanciers
donc tout ça amènerait le cause des
chiens effectivement donc la direction
actuelle sûr que être donc par la suite
assumé par le moniteur qui pourrait être
nommé mais il se serait selon moi la
moins bonne des solutions étant donné
que lorsque l'on rend dans un processus
c'est toujours extrêmement difficile de
pouvoir éventuellement mener le
l'organisation à bon port wigg des
tonnes de professionnels qui s'y intègre
par la suite c'est pas nécessairement
pour le bénéfice de l'entreprise et de
ceux et celles qui en ont fait leur
richesse
on sait que le cirque en grande partie
doit son succès
à ceux qui le font de façon quotidienne
aux artistes aux collaborateurs et c'est
important justement de faire en sorte
que cette pérennisation existe et c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous avons fait
connaître nos têtes et rennes ont fait
connaître leur intérêt est également
aussi de procurer un financement à court
terme parce que la direction a elle même
évoqué le fait - dieu il avait donc des
besoins urgents mais une aide importante
pur de pouvoir payer leurs
collaborateurs pas bougé formelle encore
vous n'avez pas déposé d'offre formelle
encore le processus en tant que telle ne
semble pas avoir démarré
nous souhaitons donc nous y était gris
dont conseillers financiers sont en
relation avec eux et c'est que nos
avocats et yvon est arrivé là
l'information transmise vendredi dernier
qui nous force à réagir
honnêtement nous aurions souhaité et
préféré que tout ce processus là se
fasse en général de la même façon que ça
s'est produit c'est à dire de façon
confidentielle
en terminant monsieur péladeau beaucoup
de défis pour la réouverture de
l'économie du québec est ce que ça vous
inquiète ce qui se passe présentement
écoutez j'ai conscience québécois j'ai
confiance en cette volonté je pense que
toutes les initiatives qui ont été
prises et à cet égard la queue musique
en est une illustration de faire en
sorte de repartir nos activités
économiques le faire avec détermination
et volonté
j'ai confiance que nous allons être en
mesure effectivement d'y arriver est ce
qu'il va voir des cicatrices
certainement les choses ne pourront pas
repartir aussi aisément que on pourrait
le souhaiter mais j'ai bon espoir que
nous allons arriver à faire en sorte que
l'économie redémarre de façon solide
bien monsieur péladeau merci beaucoup
merci monsieur fillion
merci